[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: OK, let's get started.
Welcome to the 12th
lecture of 6.006.
This is our second lecture
talking about weighted graphs,
and in particular, weighted
shortest paths, algorithms.
Last time we talked
about weighted graphs.
This is a kind of
a generalization
of what we mean by distance
in an unweighted graph instead
of each edge having a
weight of 1, essentially.
We generalize that
to be any integer.
And last time, we
showed how to solve
shortest single-source
shortest paths in a graph that
doesn't have cycles
even if it has
0 or negative weights in linear
time using an algorithm called
DAG relaxation.
We also showed in that
lecture how in linear time,
if we are given the shortest
path weights to all the things
reachable in finite--
or with shortest path
distance that's finite,
we can construct a
shortest paths tree
from those weights
in linear time.
So this is motivating
why we're not really
going to talk about parent
pointers for the next couple
of lectures.
We're just going to concentrate
on the shortest path weights.
And so today, we're
going to be talking
about our most general
algorithm we'll
be showing for solving
single source shortest paths,
in particular in graphs
that could contain cycles
and could have negative weights.
So just to recap our
little roadmap here,
single source shortest
paths in linear time.
Last time we discussed
another linear time algorithm,
DAG relaxation.
And today we're
going to be talking
about Bellman-Ford, which isn't
limited to asymptotic graphs.
In particular, there could
be negative weight cycles
in our graph.
If it has cycles, if it
has negative weights,
the worry is that we could
have negative weight cycles,
in which case there--
if a negative weight cycle
is reachable from our source,
then the vertices in
that cycle and anything
reachable from that
cycle will potentially
have an unbounded number of
edges you need to go through.
There's not a bound on the
number of edges for a shortest
path, because I could
just keep going around
that cycle as many times as I
want and get a shorter path.
And so we assign those
distances to be minus infinity.
So that's what we're going
to do today in Bellman-Ford.
In particular, what we're going
to do is compute our shortest
path distances,
the shortest path
waits for every
vertex in our graph,
setting the ones that are
not reachable to infinity,
and the ones that are reachable
through a negative weight
cycle to minus infinity, and
all other ones we're going
to set to a finite weight.
And another thing
that we might want
is if there's a
negative weight cycle
in the graph, let's return one.
So those are the
two kinds of things
that we're trying to
solve in today's lecture.
But before we do
that, let's warm up
with two short exercises.
The first one, exercise 1,
given an undirected graph,
given undirected graph G,
return whether G contains
a negative weight cycle.
Anyone have an idea of how we
can solve this in linear time,
actually?
In fact, we can do it in
order E. No-- yes, yes.
Reachable from S. I guess--
let's just say a negative
weight cycle at all.
Not in the context of
single-source shortest paths.
AUDIENCE: Detect whether
there's a negative weight edge?
JASON KU: Ah.
Your colleague has determined
an interesting fact
about undirected graphs.
If you have a negative weight
edge in an undirected graph,
I can just move back and
forth along that edge.
That's a cycle of length 2--
or I guess three vertices
back to where we came from.
There is of negative
weight, because I'm just
traversing that weight over
and over and over again.
So the question of
single-source shortest paths
of finding negative
weights is not
particularly interesting
in the undirected case.
What I can do is just for
every negative weight edge,
undirected edge in my graph, I
can just find the readability
from the vertices--
the endpoints of that edge
and label them as minus--
basically if the connected
component containing S
has a negative weight edge,
then everything in the graph
is accessible from a
negative weight cycle.
So this is not such an
interesting problem.
And so we're going to
restrict our discussion today
to directed graphs.
So this is if and only if
exists negative weight edge.
OK, exercise 2, kind of a little
preview for what's to come,
we're actually not going to show
you an algorithm directly that
meets this Bellman-Ford
running time, V times E.
What instead we're going to show
you is an algorithm that solves
single-source
shortest paths in--
So given an algorithm,
Alg A, solves
single-source shortest paths
in order V times V plus E time.
OK, what is that?
That's V squared plus
V times E. That's
close to what this V times E is.
That's what we're
going to show you.
But if I had such an
algorithm, can anyone
tell me a single-source
shortest paths algorithm--
how we can use this algorithm
to solve single-source shortest
paths in just V times E time?
Show how to solve SSSP
in order the V times E. I
guess we can put a
dot there as well.
So this is a little tricky.
It's kind of related
to the difference
we had between the
reachability problem
and the single-source
shortest paths problem
that we saw last lecture.
When are these asymptotically
different in their upper bound
is when V is asymptotically
larger than E.
But the connected
component containing S
can have at most E
vertices, or order
E. It can actually have
at most E plus 1 vertices,
because otherwise it
wouldn't be connected.
So, what we can do if we
had such an algorithm,
we could first, when we're
giving our graph, explore
everything in the
graph using BFS or DFS,
find all the things
reachable from S,
and then just throw
away everything else.
Now I have a graph for
which V is asymptotically
no bigger than E, and then
we can use this algorithm
to solve single-source shortest
paths in V times E time.
I'm not going to write
all that down here.
You can see it in the notes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this work
if your graph isn't simple?
JASON KU: Does this work
as your graph isn't simple?
I haven't thought about it.
We are not going to talk
about non-simple graphs
in this class, but
probably not because you've
got a lot of edges.
Though in our class
if we're talking
about single-source
shortest paths,
if we have multiple edges
between two vertices,
we can just take the
minimum weight one
because it's never better
to take the larger ones.
Does that answer your question?
Great.
All right.
So those are our
warm-ups, that's our goal.
We need to find an algorithm for
single-source shortest paths.
And general graphs,
graphs with--
potentially graphs with
cycles, and negative weights,
and solve it in this V
times linear kind of time.
That makes sense?
All right.
So first, before we
get to the algorithm,
we're going to
discuss a little bit
about simple short-- about
shortest paths in general.
If we didn't-- the problem
here is negative weights.
How do we find--
if we had negative
weight cycles,
there seems to be
these problems,
because we could have minus
infinities is in our deltas.
But if we didn't have
negative weights,
I'd like to assert to you
that our shortest paths, even
if there are negative weights,
are going to be simple.
They won't repeat vertices.
So that's the first thing
we're going to show you.
Let's see.
Simple shortest paths.
OK.
So, claim.
I'm going to give
my claims numbers
today just because I'm
going to have a lot of them.
If my shortest path distance
from S to some vertex
is finite, meaning it's not
infinite or minus infinite--
some finite value, there
exists a shortest path--
a shortest S to V
path that is simple.
And remember, simple means
not going through a vertex
more than once.
All right.
How are we going to prove this?
Well, consider if this
claim was not true.
If every shortest path
contained a cycle, essentially.
It repeated a vertex.
Then my path looks
something like this.
I mean, there's some vertices
along here, and then I go to V.
So here's S, and then
there's some cycle I
repeat, some vertex.
I'm going to call this cycle C.
Now what do I know
about this path?
I know that it has--
it's a shortest path
and it has finite weight.
So in particular, this
path-- this delta distance
is not minus infinity.
But if this is not
minus infinity,
what do I know about the
weight of this cycle?
AUDIENCE: It's not negative.
JASON KU: Yeah.
It can't be negative.
Because if it was
negative, I could
keep going around
this cycle, and this
would have a non-finite weight.
Shortest path distance
from S. So I know this is--
can't be negative, so it
must be 0 or positive.
But if it's 0 or positive
and this is a shortest path--
went through this cycle,
then I could remove it,
and now I have a new path
with one fewer cycle.
I could just keep doing this
to create a simple path.
So that checks out.
OK.
So, that's interesting.
If it's simple, what do we
know about the number of edges
in a simple shortest paths?
How many could
there possibly be?
How long in number of edges
could a simple shortest path
be?
If I can't repeat
vertices, I can
have at most vertices
on my simple path, which
means I can use at
most V minus 1 edges--
fence posting.
So, simple paths have
at most V minus 1 edges.
That's a nice little
thing I'd like to box off.
That's a really nice property.
So while a shortest path here
could have an infinite number
of edges, if the shortest
path distance is finite,
I know I only have
to check paths
that use up to V minus 1 edges.
In particular, this is finitely
bounded in terms of the number
of paths I have to consider.
It's exponential, potentially,
but at least it's finite.
The other way, I potentially
had to check every possible path
of which there could be infinite
if there's cycles in my graph.
OK.
So I have an idea.
What if I could find
shortest-path distances
by limiting the number
of edges I go through?
So not the full shortest
path distance from S
to V, but let's limit
the number of edges
I'm allowed to go
through, and let's
talk about those
shortest-path distances,
just among the paths that
have at most a certain number
of edges.
I'm going to call
this k-edge distance.
And I'm just going to provide
a little notation here.
Instead of having a delta,
I'll have a delta k here.
That means how many
edges I'm limited by.
So from S to V is shortest S to
V path using at most k edges.
Short-- weight-- weight of a.
Shortest path, shortest S to
V path using at most k edges.
And these notions seem
somewhat symmetric.
If I were able to compute this
thing for V minus 1, then--
for all the vertices, then
if the distance is finite,
then I'll have
successfully computed
the real shortest paths
because of this statement.
Now that doesn't mean
that if this is--
it doesn't mean the other way.
If this is minus infinity, if
the shortest-path distance is
minus infinity, it doesn't say
anything about what this is.
It just says the
shortest path using
at most V minus 1 vertices,
using at most V minus 1 edges
would be whatever this is.
But really, the
shortest path length
needs to consider an
infinite number of edges.
So it doesn't really
tell us much about that.
But for the finite ones it does.
It works well.
And so if we are able to
compute this thing for k equals
V minus 1 in a graph that
doesn't contain negative weight
cycles, we'd be done.
I claim to you a
stronger statement,
that if the shortest path using
at most V edges from s to v Is
less than-- strictly less
than delta of V minus 1--
this is all in the
subscript here.
Basically this is the
shortest-path distance
of any simple path, and possibly
ones that also contain cycles,
but definitely it includes
all the simple paths.
If there's a shorter
path to my vertex
that goes through more
than V minus 1 edges,
that this path can't
be simple, because it
goes through a vertex
more than once.
Otherwise it would be
included in this distance set.
So if this is the case,
and I found a shorter path
to V that uses v edges--
yeah, that use V
edges, that path
can't be simple, which
means that path or some path
there contains a
negative weight cycle.
So if this is true,
then I know that
the real shortest-path
distance from S to V
must be minus infinity.
I'm going to call such
a vertex a witness.
If we can find a vertex
that has this property--
I mean, I haven't shown you how
to compute these things yet,
but if I were able
to find a vertex V--
and these are capital V's
if you're having trouble.
This V is different than
this V, this is cardinality.
If we can find such
a vertex V, that
certifies that there
is a negative weight
cycle in our graph.
So I'm going to
call V is a witness.
OK.
So, if this property
is true, it's a witness
and it definitely has this.
Is it possible, you think--
I'm going to claim
to you that it's
possible that a vertex could
have minus infinite distance
but not have this property
halt. I could probably
give you an example--
I don't have one off the
top of my head right now,
but that's possible.
You could imagine,
there might be
no path going to a vertex on
a negative weight cycle that
goes through V exactly V edges.
It might go through more
edges, a shorter one.
So this equation
would be inequality
and would not certify
that this is true.
But I claim to you, if a
vertex has this property,
if it's its shortest path
distances minus infinite,
then it must be
reachable from a witness.
So that's the claim.
If delta S, V is
minus infinity, then V
is reachable from a witness.
Reachable from a vertex that
has this property-- that
has this property.
And if it's reachable
from something
that has minus infinity
shortest pathway,
then I can take that path
go to my reachable vertex,
and that's also
minus infinite path.
OK.
So how do we prove this?
Well, let's consider--
let's I'm going
to state a somewhat stronger
statement that we'll
prove instead.
It suffices to prove that
every negative weight
cycle contains a witness.
If we are to prove
that, then every vertex
with this property, every
vertex with this property
is reachable from a negative
weight cycle by definition.
So, if we can prove that every--
prove every negative weight
cycle contains witness.
If we can prove that every
negative weight cycle contains
a witness, then every vertex
reachable from one of those
witnesses-- in particular,
reachable from the negative
weight cycle--
has shortest distance
minus infinity,
and that should prove the claim.
This thing has to be reachable
from a negative weight cycle.
And so if we prove negative
weight cycles contain
witnesses, then all
of these vertices
are reachable from a witness.
OK, great, great.
Confusing myself
there for a second.
OK.
So let's consider a
negative weight cycle.
NG.
Here's a directed
negative weight cycle.
Recall.
This will be my
negative weight cycle C.
All of the sum of the
edges in this thing,
the weights has negative weight.
And I'm going to have
a little bit notation--
if I have a vertex
V here, I'm going
to say that its predecessor
in the cycle, I'm
just going to call it V prime.
That's just some notation.
All right.
So, if I have computed these
shortest-path distances
to every vertex in my graph,
shortest-path distance going
through at most V vertices
and the shortest path
distance going through at
most V minus 1 vertices,
then I know the
following thing holds.
Delta V going from S to V
for any vertex in my cycle
can't be bigger
than delta V minus 1
from S to U plus the weight--
sorry, not U-- V
prime, its predecessor,
plus the weight going from
the predecessor to my vertex.
Why is that?
Because this is the
weight of some vertex--
this is the weight--
the shortest-path
distance to my predecessor
using one fewer edge.
And so this in
particular is the weight
of some path that uses V edges.
So if this is the shortest
such path distance,
this has to upper
bound it at least--
at most.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that the
triangle inequality?
JASON KU: That is a statement
of the triangle inequality,
thank you.
All right.
So, yes, this is just
by triangle inequality.
OK.
Now what we can say is, let's
take this equation summed
over all vertices in my cycle.
So I'm just going
to add summation
here of all vertices in my
cycle of this whole thing.
I'm going to do that
out a little bit neater.
Summation of delta, not d.
Delta V S, V. I guess I don't
need this open parentheses.
Equals-- or less than or equal
to sum of V and C of delta
V minus 1 V prime.
And here, I'm
summing over V and C,
and this is just my notation
for the predecessor.
And then I'm going to sum
over the weights in my cycle
V and C. These are the sum
of the weights in my cycle.
Well, what do I know
about this cycle?
This is just the weight
of C. The weight of C--
that's awful handwriting.
C, what do I know about
the weight of the cycle?
It's negative.
So, this is less than 0, which
means that if I remove this,
this needs to be
a strict equality.
But if the sum of all
of these is strictly
less than the sum
of all these, we
can't have none of the vertices
in my graph satisfying--
not satisfying this property.
If all of them
are not witnesses,
then this thing is bigger
than this thing-- at least
as big as this thing for every
vertex in my cycle, which
is a contradiction.
So, the claim holds, if we
have a negative infinite
shortest-path distance, then
V is reachable from a witness.
So it suffices for us to
find all the witnesses,
find all the vertices
reachable from the witnesses,
and then mark them
as minus infinity.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So, now we finally are able
to get to our algorithm.
Bellman-Ford.
And what I'm going
to show you today
is a little different
than what is normally
presented as Bellman-Ford.
The original
Bellman-Ford algorithm
does something a
little different.
And because it does
something a little different,
which we'll talk
about at the end,
it's a little
hairier to analyze.
I'm going to show you
a modification that
is a little easier to analyze
and has this nice property
that we're going to be
able to use the algorithm
to give us a negative
weight cycle if it exists.
So, we're going to say this is
maybe a modified Bellman-Ford.
And the idea here is to make
a vertex associate-- make
many versions of a vertex.
And I want this
version of the vertex
to correspond to whether I came
here using 0 edges, 1 edge, 2
edges, 3 edges--
I have a different
vertex version
of the vertex for
each one of these--
for a path going
through, at most,
a certain number of edges.
OK.
So this is an idea
called graph duplication.
Idea, graph duplication.
And this is a very
common technique
for solving
graph-related problems.
Because essentially
what I get to do is I
get to store information.
If I'm having different
versions of a vertex,
I can have that
vertex correspond
to reaching that vertex
in a different state.
So that's what we're
going to do here.
The idea here is make
V plus 1 levels--
basically duplicate
vertices in our graph--
where vertex Vk in level k
represents reaching vertex
V using at most k edges.
OK, so this definition
seems similar to what
we're doing up here.
If we have vertices that
have this property, then
their shortest paths
in this new graph
might correspond to
these k edge distances.
And really, the name
of the game here
is to compute these
two for every vertex,
because then we can--
then if d is finite,
delta is finite,
then this guy will be the
length of our shortest path.
And if they are different,
that will be a witness
and we can explore from it.
So-- and if we connect
edges from one level
to only higher levels, basically
levels with a higher k, then
this graph is going to be a DAG.
Whoa.
That's cool.
Why is that cool?
Because we saw how to solve
single-source shortest paths
in a DAG and linear time.
Now this graph that
we're going to construct
is going to have
V plus 1 levels.
So could have-- our graph
kind of explodes V times.
We're going to do
that in a second.
I'm going to be more precise
with what I mean there.
But if we're multiplying
our graph V plus 1 times,
then the size of our graph
is now V times larger.
Now that doesn't-- that's
not so hard to believe.
But if we made our
graph V times larger
and we ran a shortest path
algorithm in linear time
with respect to that
graph, then that graph
has something like size
V times V plus E size.
That looks familiar, maybe?
That's this running time.
So if we can find an algorithm
that runs in that running time,
we can get down to V times E.
So let's try to do that.
Here's the transformation
I'm going to show you.
I'm going to show you
first with an example.
Here's an example of a directed
graph that does contain
a negative weight cycle.
Can anyone find it for me?
bcd.
Has weigh minus
4 plus 3 minus 1.
It has a minus 2 total weight.
So that's a negative
weight cycle.
So in order to take
shortest paths from a,
I will want to say at the end of
my algorithm, this better be 0,
and all of these better
be minus infinity.
So that's what I
want in my algorithm.
So what's my
algorithm going to be?
I'm going to make V plus
1 copies of this graph,
and I'm going to kind
of stretch it out.
OK.
So here, I have
V 0, 1, 2, 3, 4--
there are four
vertices in my graph.
So this is 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 copies of my graph.
I have a version of vertex a
for each one of those copies,
a version of vertex b for
each of those copies, c
and d, et cetera.
So I have this nice
grid of vertices.
And I'm not going to put
any edges within a layer,
within a level.
Because then-- I mean,
this graph has cycles.
And I don't want
cycles in my graph.
What I'm going to do
instead is for every edge
in my original graph-- for
example, the edge from a to b,
I'm going to connect it to
the b in the next level.
So a0 is connected to b1 with
an edge weight of minus 5,
just like in the original.
And I'm going to do that
for every edge in my graph,
and I'm going to repeat
that down all the way.
In addition, I'm going to
add zero-weight edge from a0
to a1 or from every vertex
all the way down the line.
These are all zero-weight
edges corresponding to--
I'm not going to
traverse an edge,
I'm just going to
stay at this vertex.
That's going to
allow us to simulate
this at most k edges condition.
Now if you take a look at
paths in this graph from a0,
our starting
vertex, clearly none
of the other vertices in that
level are reachable from a0,
just as we want.
Because the
shortest-path distance
to any of these vertices
using at most 0 edges
should be infinite.
I can't get there in 0 edges.
But then any path in this
graph using at most k edges
is going to correspond
to a path from a0
to a vertex in that level,
the corresponding level.
So for example, if I had a--
if I was looking
for paths 2b using
at most three edges, any path--
a path from a0 to
b3 in this graph
would correspond to a
path in this graph that
uses at most three edges.
so Let's find such a path.
So going from a0,
b1, stay at b1--
stay at b, sorry.
Yeah, that's a path using
fewer than three edges--
or at most three edges.
But there's another path here.
Where is it?
Going from a, a, a to b--
OK, that's not such
an interesting one.
That's the same path.
So I might have more than one
path in here corresponding
to a path in there, but my
claim is that any path in here
corresponds to a path in here.
So what's a path of length?
3, that's non-trivial.
Yeah, a to c to d to b.
So a to c to d to b.
Yeah, that's a path.
And basically, because
I constructed this so
that the edges always
moved from level to level,
as I traverse these edges,
I always change levels.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But my original
graph doesn't have
these self-loops with 0 weight.
JASON KU: Yes.
My original graph doesn't
have an edge from a to a.
That's true.
I'm using these edges
to correspond to--
I'm deciding not
to take an edge.
It's not that I'm like
doing any work here,
I'm just staying
there for a state.
And that's what's going to allow
me to get this at most edges.
All right.
So, this is the graph construct.
Hopefully you understand
that we made these V layers.
This is V. And a vertex--
we made V copies of every
vertex and connected
them using edges in this way.
OK.
So, first step of Bellman-Ford
is construct this graph.
So, Bellman-Ford, construct
G prime as described above.
It has how many vertices?
V times V plus 1.
V times V plus 1 vertices.
And how many edges?
Well, I have one edge for
outgoing edge for each vertex
corresponding to just
staying in the same place.
So that's V squared vertices--
I mean edges.
And then I have one edge--
for every edge in
my graph, I have--
sorry.
I have a V minus 1--
Just V. I have V edges for
every edge in my graph.
So that means-- so this
is the number of vertices.
And V times V plus
V times E, this
is V V plus E. All right, cool.
So that's how many edges I have.
So constructed in
that way, it's a DAG.
If we only have edges
going to increasing levels,
then this thing
can't have cycles,
because otherwise that
would mean there would
be an edge pointing backwards.
And we didn't
construct any of those.
All right.
So we construct
this graph G prime.
We can do that in linear time
with respect to these things.
I just go through all the
edges, I make these edges,
and I make these vertices.
It doesn't take anything--
I just do it naively.
Right I can do that in time V
times V plus E asymptotically.
OK.
Now I run DAG relaxation,
our nice algorithm
we had last time, from--
in there was a0.
I'm going to say
it's S0, our source.
Our source vertex.
Single source shortest paths.
So that I compute delta of
S0 to Vk for all k and--
what is it?
0 to V. That's what single
source shortest paths does.
It computes for me this
distance from my source--
at some source to every
other vertex in the graph.
And so in particular
I get these.
Well, that is all of them.
Then for each vertex V, set--
the thing I'm going to
return, d-value, S to V,
equal to the
shortest-path distance
I got from DAG relaxation
to a particular vertex.
V V minus 1.
Why am I doing this?
I'm setting it to be the
shortest-path distance
to the guy in the
second-to-last row here
or column in my modified graph.
The hope is that this
distance in my DAG
corresponds to this distance
in my original graph.
The distance to V using
at most V minus 1 edges.
So that's the claim--
that's a claim we're going
to prove in just a second.
I'm going to write it down
just so that we have--
just to continue our
train of thought.
Claim, delta S0 Vk equals delta
k, the k edge distance, from S
to V. That's what
we want to claim.
That would then-- what
would that mean, then?
That would mean
that I'm correctly
setting the shortest-path
distance here
for all vertices whose
distances finite.
Great.
I mean, I set values to things
where they're not finite,
where they're minus
infinity also,
but in particular I set the ones
correctly if they're finite.
OK.
So the last thing
we need to do is
deal with these minus
infinity vertices.
But we know how to do that.
We just look at the witnesses.
Because we've computed
this value for k
equals V equals V minus 1,
and if that claim over there
is true, then those
shortest-path distances
are the same as these k edge
shortest-path distances.
And we can just,
for every vertex,
we compare these things.
If this is satisfied,
we got a witness.
OK.
So for each witness U
and V where delta S0 U
V is less than, strictly,
S0 U V minus 1--
that's the definition
of a witness here,
close the parentheses.
Then for each vertex V
reachable from U set--
sorry, d, is what we're
returning, d of S, V
equal to minus infinity.
That's the end of the algorithm.
Basically I'm looking
for all the witnesses.
For each witness, I find all of
the vertices reachable from it
and set it to minus infinity
just as we argued before.
OK.
So, it remains to
prove this claim.
How do we prove this claim?
Well, we can induct on k.
Is this true for k equals 0?
Yeah.
We kind of already
argued it over here
when we are talking about
our initialization step
or what DAG relaxation does.
It'll set this to be the
shortest path from this guy
to all these vertices.
These aren't
reachable from here,
and so these are infinite.
And that one's 0.
So the base case--
so induct on k base
case, k equals 0?
Check.
That's all good.
Now we-- in our inductive
step, let's take a look
at the shortest-path
distance from 0--
from S0 to V of k
prime for some k prime.
And the assumption is,
the inductive hypothesis
is that this distance is the k
edge distance for all k prime
less than--
I mean all k less than k prime.
Well, kind of by definition
of a shortest path,
this is the minimum
overall incoming vertices
of the shortest path from
S0 to U of k prime minus 1
plus the weight of the
edge from U of k prime
minus to Vk prime for
all Uk prime minus 1
in the adjacencies, the incoming
adjacencies of Vk prime.
OK, what does this mean?
I'm just saying in
my graph G prime,
a shortest path to
this vertex needs
to go first through some
vertex in the layer before it,
which is one of these.
And in particular,
I'm only connected
to things adjacent to me.
That's all this is saying.
I have to go through that
vertex and take some shortest
path to one of those
previous vertices.
Now s actuality, these
adjacencies, I constructed them
to be similar to the
adjacencies in my original graph
in addition to one edge coming
from my original vertex,
from vertex V. So this is the
same as the minimum of this set
delta S0.
Same thing.
Plus W U, V for all U in the
adjacent-- incoming adjacencies
of my original vertex.
In addition to one more term.
What is that other term?
These are all of the
things corresponding
to my incoming edges
in my original thing,
but I also have that one edge
coming from the V before it.
So this is-- I'm
going to union--
union-- union this with delta
S0 V of k prime minus 1.
Awful.
I think there's
another one here.
This is S0 of k prime minus 1.
I"m not going to rewrite it.
OK.
Then by induction, this
thing and this thing
must be the edge shortest
paths using k minus 1 vertices.
And then that's just the
statement of what the shortest
path should be using at
most k prime edges going
from S to V. So, these things
are the same as we claimed.
Yay, check.
All right.
And then it's not such--
it's kind of a
trivial leap, then,
to say that at the end of
Bellman-Ford, these guys--
sorry, the things that
we return, these guys,
are the shortest-path
distances, because here,
if they're finite, we set them
to their true shortest-path
distance; and if
they're minus infinity,
that invariant means that these
things correspond to exactly
this claim over here.
It's a witness.
And then finding all
the vertices reachable
from those witnesses, we
set all of the infinite ones
to be minus infinity as desired.
OK, so what's the running
time of this thing?
Well, we had to
construct this graph,
so we had to take that time.
We ran DAG relaxation, that
takes the same amount of time.
For every vertex, we
did order V at work.
And then for each witness,
how many could there be?
And most, V. Checking the
reachability of each vertex,
that can be done in how long?
Order E time.
Because we don't need to
consider the things that
aren't connected to S--
or aren't connected
to the witness.
So this thing takes
order V times E work.
So we're upper-bounded
by this time
it took to construct
the original graph
and by the claim we had before,
that takes V times E time.
OK.
So that's Bellman-Ford.
I'm just going to leave
you with two nuggets.
First, the shortest path,
if for any witness--
let's say we have
a witness here.
Do I have any witnesses here?
I didn't fill in all these.
But is there a
vertex on this cycle
that goes through who
has the shortest path?
That goes through four vertices
that's smaller than any other.
OK.
I can go from a to c
to b to d to b to c.
And you can work
out this algorithm--
I have it in the notes that
you can take a look at.
This will actually have a
shorter path for vertex--
sorry.
It'll have a shorter
path for vertex b.
a to b to c to d to b.
Thank you.
That's a path of length
4, of four edges.
That has shorter path than
any path that has fewer edges.
In particular, there's
only one other path
to b using fewer than four--
there's two other paths.
One path of length--
that has one edge, that
has weight minus 5,
and one path-- this path that
has weight 9 minus 1 is 8.
Whereas this path, minus
5, minus 4, 3, minus 1
has minus 10 plus 3 is minus 7,
which is shorter than minus 5.
So b and d is a witness.
And if we actually take
a look at that path
through this graph, going from
a to b to c to d back to b
we see that there's a negative
weight cycle in this graph.
b to c to d to b.
And indeed, that's always
the case for our witnesses.
You can see a proof
of that in the notes,
and you can see in recitation
a little space optimization
to make us not have to construct
this entire graph on the fly,
but actually only use order
V space while they're going.
OK.
So that's Bellman-Ford.
Sorry for running a little late.